and today's feature presenter is
Professor Bonnie Banerjee Bonnie
Banerjee is professor of the practice at
the Stanford School of Earth energy and
environmental sciences he is also the
co-founder and director of Stanford
change labs and teaches design
innovation and strategy at the Stanford
d.school before his academic appointment
at Stanford Danny spent nearly a decade
as a technology innovation lead at the
renown design firm IDEO his area of
expertise is the use of a design
thinking for strategic initiatives and
large-scale transformations directed
toward sustainable futures regarded as
one of the leading experts in innovation
strategy in the area of sustainable
transformations he is now working with
the Dean of the Stanford School of Earth
energy and environmental sciences Pamela
Matson to shave a new academic program
around systems transformation and now
I'd like to turn the floor over to Danny
good day everyone very nice to meet you
al Viet in digital space hope to meet
you someday in person what I'd like to
speak about today is essentially the
types of innovation that you need when
the challenges have a certain set of
attributes and particularly those that
involve complexity and scale what I'm
going to cover today is our set of
topics I'm going to break it down in
this way first and foremost I would like
to make a case for a certain style of
innovation that we call systems
innovation and but since we are going
into certain nuances of innovation and
the word is used in many ways I would
like to spend some time on on innovation
itself and define innovation and then go
into two different types of
methodologies one of them is called
design thinking which many of you might
be familiar with and another which we
are recall system acupuncture at that
point in time you might ask when do you
use what type of methodology so we will
go a little bit into different types of
challenges and when to to approach where
how to pick different methodologies but
in doing that we will have touched
on issues of scale and some other
attributes about scale but this is also
a topic that is very very relevant in
terms of what types of leadership we
need for the future
so we will spend a little time on on
this notion of transformative leadership
so if we dive in what I'd like to do
before I go get into the topics of
innovation is take a few steps back and
talk about the world we find ourselves
in right now so we look at the mega
trends on the on on the way in the world
a few very very salient things jump out
one of the things that we found from a
previous few decades is that our global
economies seem to be increasingly
fragile with with very stochastic
behaviors that are caused by
perturbations anywhere in on the planet
and so we we need to prepare for
economic downturns upheavals in in rapid
timeframes our and our long term futures
in terms of whether it is business
business futures or in terms of larger
issues such as our civilization or
societal issues are being questioned by
increasing turbulence and large scale
challenges that essentially question the
very basis of of stability and of course
as we all realize our globe now is is
much more connected than it ever was but
it is not an equitable system and and
the sharp inequities caused problems
unto itself as we are seeing in the
large geopolitical issues that are that
are that are prevalent in the in the
planet today and these are no longer
abstract with political instability and
an geopolitical shift that changes the
policy landscape or or or issues of
security etc
in terms of businesses we are seeing
rapidly shifting markets very new
players and technology regimes that that
are changing at an increasing clock tick
but there's something else that's going
on we have given that we have we are in
the midst of such big changes and it is
not a secret in the general population
that we are in the midst of changes the
sensibilities are changing and who we
are catering to with what kinds of
definitions of success is changing and
and that has a lot to do with how we
craft our position and how our brand is
perceived and how our value systems are
framed and let's not forget that there
are very large changes taking place such
as climate change insecurity in or or
questions around continued security
around food water energy as we add more
than a billion people in the next few
decades and then let's also not forget
that we can normally we speak about
human issues and ansible centric kind of
point of view but we are the midst of an
environmental crisis of the sort we
haven't seen since the dinosaurs went
extinct and a whole lot of our larger
systems actually rely on the fact that
we have stable a stable biosphere so
that's something that is already
happening and we will be adding we will
be getting to 9 million people on a
limited size of a planet which is
already had more resources run from it
then it can recharge so these are all
very very large trends and one would say
that ok how does it affect my day or my
business but I would like to argue that
without keeping this in mind one might
be creating not only overlooking an
opportunity to create a better future
but also building in risk into our
businesses today or our agendas today so
what I would like to claim is that all
these megatrends indicate a world order
which is very different from the ones in
which are prevalent thinking was shaped
so if we are to meet the future we
should essentially evaluate what we have
what is in store for us in the future
what kind of challenges we are facing
and perhaps retool our ways of thinking
and and some of these challenges are
very large and scale and we are often
motivated by them or we are in the midst
of it directly or indirectly working on
them and the question is what to what
extent can be moved the needles on any
of the challenges that we are we are
facing and also recognizing that not all
problems are linear and a lot of
problems are exponential in scale but
meanwhile what we are very very good at
doing are things such as the the line
that the SQL shows and that's when the
going is good where we we are able to be
just it for a period then it scales up
and then it levels off and that's when
we are successful but that creates a
theoretical gap if the problem is
increasing at an exponential rate and
that essentially begs the question how
can we meet nonlinear problems with
nonlinear solutions and then this and
then the issue of time this is the
symbol for the time constant and every
system out there has a native time
constant whether it is it is a business
system or an institutional system or a
cultural system or all the cells in our
body or some geological force out there
if there is it goes from seconds to
years to eons but it has a clock tick
and it turns out that the clock tick of
change that we are that we are seeing is
faster than the clock tick of many of
our organizations and many of our
institutions and so we need to find ways
of intelligently dealing with the issue
of time so what we are looking at when
we take a few steps back is that
increasingly as leaders as as people who
are managing day-to-day operations as
well as big ones are we are looking at
challenges that are no longer to be well
addressed by by businesses usual methods
because these challenges are scaled
they're complex often with time frames
that are that seem unrealistic
and so you we need new ways of thinking
so what we need is is a kind of
innovation and I'll get into the
definition of innovation in just a bit
but off the type of innovation the type
of innovation that we haven't really
seen before so we need to in a sense
innovate on innovation and what I think
we need is a very radical form of
innovation that takes on the complexity
and the scale and the urgency of the
challenges so I've been using the word
innovation it gets used in very many
different ways people talk of technology
as innovation and often innovations and
innovation get used synonymously and a
clever technology is called innovation
ah the way I mean it is essentially a
way of D marketing something that's
innovative and something that's not by
saying does it outperform business as
usual does it outperform the normative
modes of working in order to drive
completely new outcomes completely new
behaviors new paradigms that rewrite the
rule books can we change the behavior of
the system and can we send it in a
different direction in the future and
that is a different eyes broader frame
for innovation so everything I go I'm
going to talk about about innovation is
with this frame which is we already have
very very good processes and and and
we've attained a certain kind of
operational excellence but it turns out
that operational excellence is not good
enough anymore so how can we outperform
the business as usual okay so that's the
that's the frame but I would like to say
that this is not just a matter of new
processes and skills but it also
involves new mindsets and new leadership
models and the leadership models would
lead to new organizational cultures and
ecosystems that would allow are these
processes to take root so that you can
outperform the business as usual now
mindsets there are many dimensions of
mindsets today I'm going to touch up
on a few mindsets and and I'm going to
frame a few very key failure modes that
you need to watch out for because if
you're not if you're falling into that
trap it means that you've written away
the opportunities that you get if you
are doing systems thinking and if you
are doing innovation correctly so first
and foremost I would say that that there
is such a thing as innovation blindness
which means that your theory of change
or success might not be directed towards
outperforming the normative modes you
have an overly you have placed a too big
face in the current system and you're
drawing your current theory of success
based on what you've done in the past
rather than what you ought to do in the
future and you're essentially writing
away the the disproportionate wins you
could have if you were to bring in an
innovation agenda now what I'm going to
do in having kind of framed innovation
in this this way is and I'm going to
talk about two different techniques and
I'm going to talk about design thinking
and then go into systems thinking but
design thinking is has become quite
popular a lot of you know about this but
I'll give you a little bit of a history
and also how perhaps a case that'll help
to explain how I am thinking about
design thinking now design thinking came
out of the design field roughly around
the around the late 1990s at the turn of
the century where designers realized
that their what they've been asked to do
was not just operational products and
services but they were also being asked
for to solve questions that were
somewhat ill defined and had to do with
with things that had to be conceived of
in the future and it turned out that the
way designers think is quite different
from how different fields operates so
just as engineering is very different
from political science is very different
from a economics designer is also quite
different and so this notion of design
thinking came about and it started
getting used in
many different ways to create
experiences of the future to which one
could design design products and
services or designing systems by the
larger systems that did many things that
many components are strategies
strategies as opposed to tactics which
mean that plans for longer-term futures
as opposed to shorter term futures and
interventions to challenges that didn't
seem to be on any one person's agenda
but they needed to be they needed to be
done in a multi-stakeholder way but also
very importantly creating visions of the
future to shoot for so in the sense you
need a certain imagination to shoot for
for a certain future that you want so
that you can direct your your your plans
and your actions towards them and Design
Thinking started getting used for that
so let me take you through a very simple
case this is a student project that was
done at Stanford in the d.school
ah and and it's a it's a very hands-on
class and students from all walks of
life and and very different disciplines
get you know brought in into an
introductory design class and this isn't
this is a journey of a student set of
students a team you know in an
introductory design class so they were
given a challenge and around around
infant mortality so in in the world over
four million of the 130 babies that are
born every year die in the first 28 days
and one of the primary causes today is
low birth weight premature babies
premature babies do not have enough
subcutaneous fat in their body to
regulate their temperature so the the
normative technique for the last last
one hand over 100 years has been to put
them in incubators where their body
temperature can be artificially
regulated and and so incidentally the
incubator term comes from the poultry
industry where the technology was stolen
from incubating eggs and and the
modern-day incubator costs upwards of
$20,000 but a lot of these
babies are born in developing countries
with lots of social and economic issues
and they cannot afford $20,000 so this
team was asked to chop two zeros from
the cost make it into $200 instead of
$20,000 the theory that if you could
make a cheaper a whole lot of these
countries that have the problem of
large-scale infant mortality because of
slow premature birth they could deal
with it now let's look at the journey
that these students performed with the
Design Thinking guidelines so first and
foremost instead of taking a typical
approach of the slashing cost by by
looking at the cost of goods and making
things cheaper and knock down and and
making the feature simpler they actually
took the trouble to go to the places
where this was happening they went to
rural India and Bangladesh and looked at
these small regional hospitals in
failure mode areas and much to their
surprise they found that these hospital
had incubators they actually possessed
incubators but they also found something
very interesting that you must be
noticing that there are no babies in
them so that really puzzled them and
they said why are they no babies in the
incubator and so they started digging
into it and they realized that actually
the the problem was that the people to
the families to whom the the babies are
born lived in very tiny remote areas and
they were day laborers and they could
not afford the cost to to avoid a tube
to bring the baby to the regional
hospitals so this is the point at which
one of the most important theorists took
place they went against the brief that
their their partners had given them and
they said we do not need the 200 dollar
baby incubator we need a 20 dollar baby
warmer that can work without electricity
particularly because they also noticed
that a lot of these remote areas had
intermittent power so if you had
something that could run on electricity
and it failed then the baby would die so
they reframed what the problem brief was
and they came back and according to the
design principles they brain
stun the bottom left shows you that they
came up with many many ideas and they
quickly went into a rapid prototyping
phase where they tried out many many
solutions in very rough and crude ways
and they they bought materials from
grocery stores from hardware stores and
cobble things together with Tupperware
and so on in order to explore the idea
and quickly test them and one of the
ideas that came about was why not make
something like a like a sleeping bag for
a baby but also put an insert in it
which was made out of some kind of phase
change material which the first
prototype is made out of margarine and
wax from from a grocery store and if you
put
recrystallization is something that can
be used to keep the baby warm and hot
water is something you can find anywhere
and so that's was the idea that one out
among a lot of contesting ideas and just
to give you a sense they came up with
over 180 ideas and they made over 80
prototypes in a matter of a few weeks so
that's how fast they moved and and then
didn't stop there they took these to the
villages back and they learned a lot of
lessons that and lots of failure modes
that would essentially take them down in
the last mile off concerns by many
stakeholders who constituted this
stakeholder set and the definition of
they learned the definition of the
customer in that there is the entire set
of people who can aid or impede your
cause so they found out the opinions of
the Midwife they found out about the
regional doctors they found out about
people who would the regulators etcetera
etcetera they found out that people are
not literate and they might not
understand when the thing is too hot so
that changed their brief so they came
back and kept prototyping fast forward
these people after the class they just
started a tiny little startup they got a
fun from a grant from a wall a
non-profit or or a foundation and they
came up with the product that is now
being being it's one every design of
what there is to win there is it's being
is being distributed by by big big
players such as GE Healthcare it has
saved tens of thousands of life if not
hundreds of thousands they are
backordered it's made a big difference
in in in the in the issue of infant
mortality now if you look at the system
if you're a hardcore engineer you
wouldn't be impressed is very very
simple now if it is this simple the
question to ask is then why did it elude
the medical community for 150 years
right it's not for want of billions of
dollars worth of research funding so
here is the secret sauce the process
involved actually taking the trouble to
go out and seek insights without from
and deep human considerations without
preconceived ideas without preconceived
theories look being being naive and open
to what might really be happening
reframing the problem statement in terms
of those and then being extremely
generative to create concepts and
prototypes and then testing them so that
you can generate fresh insight again but
the main the big big differentiator is
that they did not ask the wrong question
they did not say how can we design in a
cheap incubator they said how can we
keep babies alive and just that
difference send you sends you in a
different part so that in a nutshell is
how Design Thinking operates the long
process with lots of tools but at enough
level of abstraction that's how it works
right now there are many types of
challenges and one can ask whether is
Design Thinking sufficient right now if
you if you think a little deeply one of
the things that this did is it looked at
some of the failure modes at the human
level and it looked at at the lives of
the people etc but one of the failure
mode modes to think about is that even
though this had a certain system's
thinking involved in it there is such a
thing as being system blind where your
theory of success doesn't take into
account the larger system dynamics and
the complex interaction of different
factors so Design Thinking is absolutely
beautiful when it comes to the interface
between the system and the human and
often it can change certain aspects
about the system but it doesn't it's not
necessarily a good tool to change the
larger system itself for that you need a
tool such as such as such a system
acupuncture and in order to explain what
that is I'm going to explain what some
of the distinctions are
there are this is the Keene oven model
by Snowden and it frames four different
types of challenges one of them is
simple the others complicated the third
is complex in the fourth is chaotic but
simple is a self-evident system such as
a door lock or a French press or where
you can you can you know it if you don't
need instructions in how to how to work
that system a complicated system is like
a car or a Swiss watch where you need
it's very complicated many parts many
many couple systems and you need
expertise in order to deal with it ah
but the subsystems are are are are
predictable in what they do and you can
bring a whole lot of what is called
deterministic thinking into in solving
these complex problems however are ones
where there are Meza dance between many
different components and unless you
understand the dynamics of that dance
the chances that you would be able to
influence it in the way you want to is
low and and you need to understand it in
terms of the relationships so it's like
a forest where many many components have
symbiotic relationships and that gives
you the larger construct which is the
forest and chaotic is when something is
happening because of which the
relationships are changing very very
quickly like a forest fire where you
where the the processes are something
that are very becoming increasingly
unconstrained and things are changing
very very quickly where the influence
you have on the system is very low now
it turns out that most of our systems
happen to be fall in the complex realm
but most of our decision-making cultures
and tools are for complicated systems so
we bring the tools or one type of system
to a different type of problem and there
lies one of the reasons why we are
unable to come up with systemic
solutions to systemic problems
and if you have a system that is going
into chaotic states you need to arrest
it very very quickly so and because the
level of influence that you have it
drops very rapidly so imagine you're
cooking and suddenly the kitchen catches
fire that is not the time to go do your
dishes that's the time to put out the
fire before and you have a small window
of time turns out that a lot of our
larger systems are entering or already
into chaotic states so we need to find
interventions very very quickly to those
so if you are in and I would argue that
there's complexity in the simplest of
things if you are at a dining table
conversation with an extended family
that's a complex system and unto itself
right but a lot of the the big things
that we talked about in setting the
stage we as organizations as in markets
that are changing that rapidly we are
definitely in the complex run so the
mindset to to have is watch out for for
whether a system is complex or simply
simple or complicated and if there are
systemic challenges they ought to be met
with systemic solutions and if they
involve scale then you have to have your
solutions involve scale as well so if
you look at this another way we can see
that there are many ways in which to to
categorize challenges but there are
challenges that are bounded in nature
where very predictable systems however
complicated and the business-as-usual
systems work pretty well out there when
you have ill-defined challenges but
where the boundary conditions are fairly
tight such as how do you create a
service that has is engaging to to a
diverse customer set now that's a pretty
open-ended question however it's
somewhat bounded because all you're
dealing with is engagement of a certain
customer set then that is something that
tools innovation tools such as Design
Thinking is sufficient however if you're
trying to transform the system itself
that's a Class C kind of challenge and
that's where you need
that's where you need more assistance
thinking and more more tools that deal
with the complexity and scale
incidentally for those of you who are in
organization types that have to do deal
with business success
it is also closely tied to the
difference between the red ocean
strategies and blue ocean strategies red
ocean strategies relates to strategies
where it's where the margins are low
there's very little differentiation
where the waters red with the blood of
the sharks going out to the same food
but blue ocean strategy is where you're
able to innovate and create a space
where there are relatively few
competitors and you're creating value
then rather than simply capturing value
and you're creating markets that that
you get to write the rule books in the
competitors will come but if you create
an innovation capacity you have created
a capacity to stay one step ahead so
these two concepts are actually tied
which also implies that business success
is also closely related to working
towards future systems that are
desirable and there are ways to do it
now we have at Stanford a change labs
which I head we've come up with a
methodology which we call system
acupuncture which has many tools and a
process rket cetera that I'll go into a
little bit but it involves a theory of
framework a set of processes and tools
and integrate systems thinking design
thinking and an architecture around
scale a very kind of nuanced way of
looking at scale building in a lot of
theories from other fields such as
resilience Theory leverage points
economic complexity but making it very
accessible and ways in which one can use
it but also recognizing that behavior
the behavioral component and the social
component is a very very large component
and whether or not an innovation
diffuses through a community is very
important and there's a ton of research
out there which can return into
principles and design tools so we do
that as well and we are reframing what
technology business and organizational
change strategy looks like by looking at
the non-linearity of it and how do you
change cultures but also using nonlinear
technology new ways new business
models such as platform thinking etc and
and a certain kind of integration into
not just looking at single outcomes but
simultaneously looking at multi outcome
strategies and that in elegant ways so
that is what the process looks like but
what we are somewhat fetishistic about
is are we creating scale impact we are
we creating a deep transformation in the
system behavior and if the current
system is headed towards a certain
predictable future that we do not like
or we are concerned about the stability
or the resilience of can we do something
to send it toward the different
different future and create a position
for ourselves where it's win-win
we are able to deal with impending
changes or potential changes in ways
that we can navigate those waters with
better better seamanship and can we can
we actually take charge of the future
and and and position ourselves so that
we have more influence in which way the
future actually goes so the direction
makes a makes a big difference but also
can we come up with outcomes the Delta
is a is a sign for change so if we were
to take on aspirational goals and part
of innovation is creating extremely
aspirational goals and then trying to
working really hard to meet them and my
argument is that actually having greater
aspirations is a very big component of
innovation if you did not shoot for the
moon you it would be unlikely that you
would get to the top of even a tall
building you need a large target in
order to get there to direct your
thinking so if you have a large chasm
between the current massive challenge in
the future how do you how do we get to
that how do we bridge that chasm and and
of course you cannot get jump a chasm in
two leaps a single leap you have to
cross a chasm in a single leap so or you
need to build a bridge so let's see what
you need to do
in terms of this philosophy of system
acupuncture first of all the term comes
with the admission that brute force
methods are not going to work because
you simply do not have the resources you
have to be elegant in how you use
resources and so then the the metaphor
is acupuncture where you look into the
system with enough intelligence to to
have a theory about where you should
place your interventions in clever ways
such that you change the behavior of the
system and you get the outcomes in the
most resource effective and actionable
ways which is also very very leveraged
so if you look at this this chasm the
first step to look at is you need to
envision a future that is different
because you are doing that implicitly
anyways even if you if by placing your
belief in business is usual because you
have bought into the vision that the
business as usual implicitly has but if
you are trying to change the future it
is worth taking the time and using the
tools in order to cast the future
anyways and then you're building a
bridge that involves a few steps so you
envision the future so you actually do
there's another step before that is
creating the preconditions for success
but then the steps in the innovation
process is envisioning the future from a
systems perspective understanding what
the system what makes the system take
and then doing the work it takes to
create a theory of change in terms of
systems acupuncture points now that you
have the makings of a strategy at a high
level saying that if we change this at
and that theoretically we should change
then you design your intervention and
that turns into more higher level
fidelities of platform architectures or
process architectures or organization
change theories of processes and so on
it can go in many different directions
data plans or finer or market models or
what have you product services but then
you have to turn it into action that is
that has the potential to scale and you
have to think about scale at every every
step and essentially baked-in scale so
that's something that
talk about as well so that essentially
is the arc but when you do that what we
do is we take a certain lens we are
looking at the behavior at the system
level and the human level we look look
at everything to the scale lens we look
at at the ecosystem of of what's
happening in the larger ecosystem not
just put the blinders on on our
technology or our focus and we
definitely take the innovation lens of
what can be changed in a radical way in
a disproportionate way we do that in the
time we are understanding the system we
do that when we are strategizing and
when we are designing solutions so those
are the lenses we use and so let let me
say that you could do all of this and
still have another failure mode you
could have be scale blind and and that
means that you could you could do
something where you somehow had a had a
head of you that some it's going to
scale automatically just because the
problem is scaled and that's what
motivates you your solution is going to
scale as well and you're actually going
to be able to move the needle well what
we understand from our research is scale
is inordinately hard to stuff and after
the fact there's the DNA of your
solution if it doesn't have scale then
you have to get inordinately lucky to
have scale so if you are not banking on
on blind luck then you need to
incorporate from the principle of scale
and first and foremost you need to
become scale minded you have to build
and scale ability at the onset you need
to obsess about it at every scale and
you need to build in non-linearity if
your problems involves non-linearity now
there are many aspects of scale many
dimensions to scale one can just go by
traditional metrics of numbers you have
to first ask ourselves can you enter at
scale or I used where you have no option
of entering that scale what is going to
allow you to scale to do scaling that
distinction itself is a very important
distinction but scale is always tied
tight to time it's inseparable from time
because if you had unlimited resources
and unlimited
time you would eventually get scale but
we don't have a hundred years and we
don't have unlimited amounts of time so
there's a time constant built in in two
scales so we can't be time blind either
particularly if the problems are running
away from us or the industry is changing
rapidly we need to understand the
nuances of time as well so if we have to
talk about some these things as mindsets
for the transformative leader as if some
of the top lines are many many different
things but some of the things to worry
about is are we being impact minded are
we really being changed minded are we as
you wearing the innovation hat or are we
being risk averse to the point of being
risky where we have baked in so many
business processes that are that that
abort failure or are are scared of risk
that we've also brought down the ceiling
for what kind of ideas ideas can be
brought and either we are losing out an
opportunity for for making occupying a
completely different position or leaving
them I ourselves wide open to other
people who would do be innovative and
essentially upstages we have to be
system minded and that's a whole
perceptual lens by which one can look at
look at the world and our work and this
is a very different way of life than
procedural ways that are that look at
complicated systems and for those of you
in the technology field a lot of our
training they're trains us for for
complicated systems but not for system
can't complex systems we need to be
scale minded time minded and process
minded because if we have a good sense
of process and we can hack the processes
itself and being nuanced about how we
use a process process can be a great
proxy for leadership
it gets you those things that
extraordinary leadership gets you and
because of our challenges this is not a
single sport it's not a single
stakeholder sports so we need to find
ways and B to be very Co creative and
engaging multiple stakeholders we need
to envision alternate futures and drive
towards them
and there is a huge part to create being
facilitating and catalyzing action to
the extent that you're also creating
leadership modalities among people who
might be very young or might not have
very much experience but you need to
have them fall into leadership
modalities and ultimately you're
creating an ecosystem for systemic
change so what we are looking at is
essentially that which a certain kind of
leadership that will be able to increase
the innovation and the transformation
transformation capacity of your team
first of all of yourselves then the team
then your division then your
organization including what position
your organization has in the industry
the entire industry itself and in multi
industry multi-stakeholder multi sector
ecosystems and all of that the degree to
which it can be innovated on and
transformed is up to how we approach it
and what kind of methodological tools we
bring to it and what kind of value
systems we bring to it so ultimately
what we are trying to do is move the
needle on extremely profound challenges
and create a world where where we have a
place in doing excellent business and
are and we have a position which is
resilient and pointed towards better
futures so we need to worry about the
potency of the intervention whether the
scale is is relevant in times that are
relevant and and thus can build a
diffusion scale and the degree to which
it's integrated in the existing complex
system rather than of being a figment of
one's imagination which is very very
hard to actualize so I'll end there and
we'll invite some questions and so I'm
looking at the questions and there are
some record questions there the people
who are asking about examples of an
exponential problem well an exponential
problem is essentially where when you
look at us from from a systems
perspective it is typically caused
because of some kind of a
for feedback loop where a causes B B
causes C and maybe you know am there
many steps later but if if a causes B
and because of C but C causes a again
then the effect is color is also
contributing to the cause and it creates
a feedback loop and particularly if you
have a high gain rate you can actually
get an exponential problem so in the in
and at a planetary scale the fact that
we have lost a whole lot of our polar
icecaps
means that a whole lot of white
reflective land mass is being reflected
is being replaced by dark absorptive
landmass and the heat gain is increasing
which means that the temperature of the
oceans is increasing at a much faster
rate when and causing the ice to melt
even faster so this is an example of a
feedback loop but if you find any
rapidly changing equation particularly
if it's tied to a population issue so if
you have a finite a finite resource such
as water or energy energy is not exactly
finite but at any given time the
capacity over over a short period time
might be finite but then you in that
time frame if you have a rapid increase
because of population pressures or an
influx into the city etc then you're
seeing a certain kind of you might have
feedback loops where some issue is is
raising it being raised not a linear
scale but either at a an exponential
scale or with step functions and you see
that both in positive and negative ways
you could get sudden collapses and sit
in systems such as if you get at his
threshold functions in the level of
density in a city the entire the
transportation system can come to a
grinding halt and that's a nonlinear
effect as well so there are some other
questions here there was a question
about the Ruka world I think that those
of you who attended another webinar by
Julia she mentioned the Warka world
volatile uncertain complex and ambiguous
that's exactly what we are we are
talking about that's another term for
the for the big backdrop that I
explained that we are in an increasingly
bukavu
and even those of you who are in
industries where you feel that you have
captive markets and you have technology
portfolios that are very trust that you
can trust and market positions that you
can feel very confident about think
about how rapidly things the established
industries have been disrupted in the
past think about the transportation
industry the hotel industry and you know
who I'm talking about right now so let
me read the questions so there was a
question about the the three bubbles
that are used in the arch and and while
I talk about that I'm going to try and
move back to the to that slide is like
if I may so the three bubbles was
essentially at the stages this is a
slide at each stage there is a certain
lens you can have now the perceptual
lens is the lens you have when you look
at something so if you're supposing you
have a scenario such as such as a cafe
and there are all these people who are
working some older people some younger
people some people on on computers some
people in in like and some people who
are discussing with paper and some
people who are just chatting and having
coffee and you for people coming to the
room and one of them is an engineer the
other the social scientists the third is
an economist the fourth of the
structural engineer I am exaggerating of
course but if you ask them what you see
they would see completely different
things one person would see look how
many people of different racial types
and origins of ethnic origins someone
else would look at Hey look at the how
how snazzy the technology is and
everybody's on Wi-Fi and everybody is
connected and everybody's on cell phone
somebody else would say Wow look at the
building structure and this is the
happening this kind of building is
happening in a Seesmic zone I'm
wondering if they have structural
structural support behind the buildings
you just see different things if you
with the perceptual lens that you come
in with so if you deaf
implicit in everything that we do and it
makes our vision sharpen in certain
things and dollar and other things so if
you are in a technology-based company
you look at the world through the the
technology which is of course something
you need to do but there's a risk of
having the hammer to a hammer everything
looking like a meal and what we say is
that there is no way to avoid a
perceptual lens so we will choose which
perceptual lens we should have and we
will look at it from the point of
behavior and behavioral frames there are
many ways in which to decode behavior
and D spaghettify behavior we are going
to I said we have to obsess about scales
so we there is a nuanced way of in in
which you're asking the scale question
in understanding the problem and and
solving the problem and you understand
the problem using what are the scales
dynamics what is change what are the
dynamics are causing things to change
and what our opportunities to enter in
scale and you're not just saying look
just if you're in the in the food
business or you're in the energy
business you are not just looking at
energy if you're a modern day
organization that is related to energy
you're not in the business of selling
electrons energy is a lifeblood of off
of the economy and it touches all our
lives and there are a million ways in
which systems are changing which has an
energy footprint in it and there are
many many ways of looking at much better
and sophisticated ways of looking at
energy that you can only glean and and
understand if you look at the larger
ecosystem of different things that are
happening sociological changes different
actors value chains supply chains
technology emergencies etc and
innovation I already explained that you
have to be a little very aggressive
about that okay we can with common sense
we get a certain kind of answer but
common sense is not common sense you
have to do better than common sense you
have to do it such that an ounce of
thinking should get you a ton of results
and there is a mindset and it's an
innovators mindset and just because
people are giving you constraints that
seem impossible it just means that we
have to get smarter and we have to
create win-win strategies so one of the
examples of innovation mind frame is
very often we pit the short-term against
the long-term the moment we pit the
short-term against the land long term we
are saying that we are not going to be
innovative enough to meet both criteria
so we actually say let's do the short
term first or let's just focus on the
long term but there if you're innovative
you should be able to take on both and
the just by putting that frame you will
find solutions okay so let's see it but
the few minutes left I'm going to pick a
few other questions our transformation
capacity is not a small feat it is and
it's not a small answer ah
is it a start is the starting point to
try to transform organizational mindsets
to believe that they can transform so
the question is around given that the
aspiration of big transformation is it
seems enormously hard where do you start
and what are simple places to start and
if you look at the change models of of
change itself or transformation and if
you're not and an organization the way
to think about it is do the small
changes can have a disproportionate
effect and instead of trying to create a
blanket change in your entire
organization and saying oh my god my
bosses you should meet my boss they'd
never agree to this or you should meet
my board they'd never allow you to do it
or do you realize how constrain my
industry is and when I'm you know and
how regulated my industry is and so on
or do you expect you think that the
shareholders are going to tolerate this
etc these are questions when I do work
with large organizations I this is
standard questions and we get it is
possible to actually create change in
very strategic ways but also simple ways
change your team change first of all
think about how you yourself are going
to change for change your team but also
create small
in terms of change small intervention of
change that have a way in which to
expand and and so there is a hole so yes
organizational change and change in
organizational culture and mindsets
is a very very important dimension of
change and that is one of the first
things you should target but one of the
ways in which to do that is to also
target some highly practical initiatives
that will give serve as a vessel for
that change so you're all delivering our
new product strategy at the same time as
which you're making changes internally
so what would be a good strategy that we
can apply to forecast the future of a
particular industry now that is the so
you're trying to essentially gaze into
the future and you're essentially saying
look a lot of it is changing and so what
you're going to the best way of doing
this is I would say two tools one of
them is a broader systems mapping
identifying the the forces at play and
the dynamics that influence your
industry and your industry influences so
those two aspects so if you understand
what is influencing your industry and
what is what is what it influences and
then also figure out whether their
feedback loops are there and ask
yourself what are the dominant drivers
and what among those are changing and
the second tool is essentially foresight
which is essentially saying what are the
events that are probable that could
happen that are not necessarily highly
likely but could happen or what are the
bigger changes that are happening and
what does that mean for our industry and
essentially going through a process and
and then you essentially prioritize the
drivers in terms of probability and
salience and that gives you a map of
where your industry is likely to move
you can find gravity wells that that
would have and markets that are opening
up that'll suck your your your industry
in that direction or create impediments
well thank you very much Manny we're at
the top of the hour here so
unfortunately we will not have enough
time for additional questions
but hopefully you all have enjoyed the
webinar and information that has been
presented as much as I have I'd like to
encourage all of you again to visit our
website global impact Stanford etu and
find out more information about the
program that will be offering September
and hopefully we can see many of you
with us here on campus and with that I
wish you all a good rest of the day and
look out for the recording of the
webinar which should be coming to you
within the week thank you very much
thank you very much and hope to see you
in person in September